let's review okay four types of decision
support systems and by the way just as I
am this is a biodome I how many times
have I told you that there are four
types of decision support systems I've
lost count how many times you probably
think you find out I'm sinking this we
know this already I'm number one you
probably don't know it actually as much
as you might think and under under you
know pressure sometimes things you think
you know you don't know okay
secondly the way that we learn stuff
well is is by repetition actually
ironically or maybe not ironically very
deliberately that's kind of what this
today's topic is about repetition in its
importance for learning okay sir let's
see the for okay and I'm actually gonna
elicit something important out of this
one we have a look at them start with
the simplest what was the most basic
kind of decision swatches to look that
spreadsheet okay good
upper level of complexity and cost what
was next
relational database and most recently we
spend a little bit of time looking at XO
sisters yes not to be confused with the
humans here we call experts
right so the idea was from one to three
right we're getting increasing levels of
sophistication right which is great they
can make more a broader range of
decisions and more complicated ones but
you get this added level of complexity
and how much time you've got build and
design these kinds of things right a
spreadsheet we could knock together in a
few minutes and it can be quite simple
do the job just fine whereas an expert
system these kinds of things they need
teams of programmers and knowledge
engineers and the actual experts in a
domain to make one of these come in
buddy now here's the feet though for all
of their differences okay there's one
key weakness that all of these types of
decision support systems share
okay and it's that when you want to make
something with these number one and
number two when you actually wouldn't
use it right it requires a tremendous
amount of human intervention so number
one you got to design the thing right
and then often to use it you have to go
we give her very very kinds of very
specific clients and inputs and that
kind of thing and I wanted to get
something meaningful out of it and also
as a situation might change or you know
you need some adaptation right you're
gonna have to come back to this human
design right in order to make updates to
how the system makes decisions okay so
suppose we learn something new about
save web app okay some groundbreaking
new discovery and so our exit system
though we were using to predict whether
right is gonna have to be manually
updated and change and that's probably
gonna be a very complicated process okay
so yeah that's a real challenge
right and it's it runs contrary to the
basic way that us humans make decisions
right nearly that we learn and we change
and after making many many decisions
that's how you get good and making
decisions that's how experts become the
experts so that's what I'm getting out
here what's the main drawback shared in
common between all three of these
previous types of decision support
systems they can't change of their own
accord okay if we want to update them if
we want them to be better we have to do
it ourselves right and you know from a
programmers point of view your system
you are all the things that you can do
are things that you have taught it how
to do right every function every actual
operation that it can do is specified by
the programmer okay that's it a
traditional sort of you know view of
programming so